Netflix is constantly churning out high-quality
entertainment, but there's so much of it in
the works that it can be hard to keep track
of what's ahead.
Here are some of the most intriguing upcoming
Netflix originals to get pumped about.
After decades of delighting the world with
his manic Muppets, Jim Henson and his progressive
partners in puppetry released the dazzling
and ambitious The Dark Crystal in 1982.
This serious, hardcore fantasy epic with shades
of Tolkien focused on mythical races vying
for control of a powerful gem that keeps order
in the universe.
"This is a piece of the dark crystal!"
It was a box office hit and a cult classic
and now Netflix is revisiting it.
The Dark Crystal: Age of Resistance will be
a prequel series, set long before the events
of the film, relying on old school puppetry
instead of CGI.
There's no hard release date yet, but expect
the Age of Resistance to hit the streaming
service sometime before 2020.
The breakout star of one of the most popular
and critically acclaimed sci-fi TV shows of
all time is making her way back to a space-set
series.
Katee Sackhoff, aka Starbuck from the Battlestar
Galactica reboot, has signed on to star in
an upcoming Netflix thriller called Another
Life.
In this dark science-fiction drama that sounds
like equal parts Alien and The Orville, Sackhoff
stars as Niko Breckinridge, an astronaut who
leads a crew on a spooky trip to explore the
origins of an important artifact of an alien
civilization.
Another Life boasts a notable pedigree: it's
produced by Halfire Entertainment, the company
that made Netflix's acclaimed adaptation of
Margaret Atwood's Alias Grace.
There's room enough in the infinite expanse
of Netflix for another show about the infinite
expanse of space.
Like Another Life, Away is a show about astronauts,
but this one is much more grounded in reality.
Based in part on Chris Jones' 2014 Esquire
article of the same name about astronaut Scott
Kelly, the drama is about Emma Green, a fictional
American astronaut struggling with leaving
her family behind for her one-year trip into
the wild black yonder.
Get your tissues ready: Away is probably going
to be a tearjerker, because of the man behind
it: It's the co-creation of Jason Katims,
the mastermind behind beloved TV weepfests
Friday Night Lights and Parenthood.
The King Arthur legends have been part of
the cultural fabric of England for well over
a thousand years, and these legends get adapted
into movies and TV shows with regularity because
people know and love them… and also because
they're squarely in the public domain.
Legendary graphic novel creator Frank Miller
will publish his own take, told from the point
of view of the Lady of the Lake.
Cursed won't hit bookstores until late 2019,
but Netflix has already recognized the pull
of the material, and put a serialized version
of the book into production starring Katherine
Langford, best known for anchoring the service's
controversial hit 13 Reasons Why.
Visionary filmmaker Guillermo del Toro is
a beloved fixture of the horror-fantasy genre,
with a filmography that runs from dark fable
Pan's Labyrinth to his more recent hit The
Shape of Water.
Thanks to a deal with Netflix, del Toro will
revisit his roots in the scary filmmaking
he so obviously loves.
With the success of Netflix's own Black Mirror,
unsettling anthology series are back in a
way not seen since the heyday of The Twilight
Zone in the '60s.
The service wants more, and more scary, so
it's ordered 10 installments of Guillermo
del Toro Presents 10 After Midnight.
According to Variety, del Toro will produce
the series while also curating the stories
he wishes to tell, and will personally hire
interesting filmmakers to make those standalone
episodes.
He's also slated to write and direct a few
of the episodes himself.
With shows such as GLOW, Unbreakable Kimmy
Schmidt, and Master of None, Netflix helped
popularized the notion of single-camera, film-like
comedy series.
But Netflix is all things to all people, so
it's also explored the classic sitcom format
with The Ranch, Fuller House, and soon, No
Good Nick.
This three-camera family comedy stars two
very familiar faces: Sean Astin and Melissa
Joan Hart.
They play parents Liz and Ed, a career-oriented
mom and goofy dad who bring into their family
a 13-year-old named Nicole, only to slowly
realize that she's actually a con artist with
inscrutable goals.
From Wet Hot American Summer-quoting comedy
nerds to devoted Ant-Man-loving MCU acolytes,
just about everybody loves Paul Rudd.
He's starred in a couple of Netflix original
movies, and he's set to star in his first
series for the online giant.
From the mind former Daily Show executive
producer Timothy Greenberg and directed by
Little Miss Sunshine duo Jonathan Dayton and
Valerie Faris, Rudd's latest Netflix project
is Living With Yourself.
Rudd stars as a man for whom life did not
turn out so well, and so he submits to an
experimental self-improvement treatment.
One problem: His replacement is his newer,
better self… and that's also his new rival.
Joe Hill and Gabriel Rodriguez's fantasy/horror
title Locke & Key is one of the most popular
and well-received comics in recent memory.
Three siblings move into the Massachusetts
home that's been in their family for generations,
where they find special keys that give them
all magical and superhuman abilities.
Just two years after its first issue hit newsstands
in 2008, Hollywood got to work on an adaptation
for television.
And it's been in the works ever since.
Hill will write on the 10-episode series,
while Carlton Cuse of Lost is onboard as a
producer and developer.
Scandal's Darby Stanchfield is attached to
star.
Netflix has blossomed into such an entertainment
juggernaut that it's able to attract and more
than decently compensate content creators
from the world of traditional television.
The latest is prolific writer/director/producer
Ryan Murphy, who helped make FX into a prestige
channel, drawing huge ratings and winning
tons of Emmys for American Horror Story and
American Crime Story.
Netflix offered Murphy $300 million the most
lucrative producer contract in TV history
to do whatever he wants on the streaming platform.
The first of what will likely be many Ryan
Murphy series feels very on-brand: Ratched,
a prequel series to the classic film and novel
One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest.
"I want that television set turned on right
now!"
It focuses on Nurse Ratched, the no-nonsense
nurse played by Louise Fletcher in the 1975
movie version of Ken Kesey's book.
Frequent Murphy collaborator Sarah Paulson
will take over the role for the series.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.